maybe we'll play it later on the show I
I saw some deep fakes in my voice going
around so a friend of mine sent me a
deep fake voice generator it is the
creepiest and scariest thing I've ever
seen it took two seconds to upload a
clip of Ian's voice and we can make Ian
say anything and they will oh they will
now here's the best part when I tried it
on me it didn't work why not right I
have no idea but I'm glad it didn't
really yeah it didn't work it just
sounded bad it doesn't sound like me at
all wow it weirdly just doesn't sound
like me and I'm like okay that's a good
thing maybe I got a weird voice and I
talk like a weird person you're immune
to The Matrix well maybe there's
something like most people talk a
certain way so the AI takes a person's
voice and applies it to like a standard
set of an algorithm that applies to most
people and then generates it and for me
it just didn't really work cool maybe we
can listen to those later